[Music]
my grandma is my queen
engineer by education
she started her career as a rocket
scientist at 22.
at 46
she became director of a summer camp for
kids
at 69 she left this position
no not for retirement
but to become an hr manager for the
rocket science company she used to work
before
she retired only 13 years later at 82
beloved by everyone
who was lucky enough to work with her
she is now 88 and oh my god you should
see the flowers and veggies she is
growing at her country house
my grandma's career pass with its
multiple pivots into her 80s is
extraordinary for her time
but she's a forerunner of how a career
should look like
nowadays we have a good chance to live
until 100 and beyond
we are aging so much healthfully
this is exciting we can accomplish so
much more during our lifetime
but to take advantage of this gift of a
long life
we must prepare for career longevity
i want to offer you three ideas of how
to do this
number one
start thinking of your career as a
portfolio
not as a straight line
for many years we have thought of a
successful career as of something linear
it has a beginning a peak
and an assumed decline
the idea of career longevity brings a
portfolio approach
plan your career as a set of activities
project directions like my grandma
portfolio approach guarantees more
stability
and more fun
is achieved by diversifying your
professional capabilities
the world is changing so quickly
professions rise and die so do companies
just as an investing
betting on just one thing
is risky
so diversify your career portfolio to
gain more stability and lessen the risk
of becoming irrelevant
but also look at it from the fun angle
you have gained an additional 30 years
of life
some of that should definitely go to
doing something interesting
ask yourself
what else do i want to do create a wish
list and start working on it now
i try to keep the growing list for
myself
start my own company
do something for climate change
become a lecturer at stanford
get a medical degree
suggestion number two
is to train yourself to be flexible
it is very scary to adapt to rapid
changes if you are not used to this
nowadays the key competitive advantage
is how quickly one can
handle the uncertainty adapt to new
realities and learn new skills
my practical advice to anyone regardless
of age
is to train yourself to be flexible by
studying something challenging
programming
a new foreign language arts something
that your brain doesn't like
for me
it became math
the last couple of years i've made
myself working on math problems every
week
in the beginning
it was torture
but now it's fun
suggestion number three is more of an
ask
shape the future by building
multi-generational teams
multi-generational teams are rare in
business now
younger people often resist older
employees and older employees sometimes
struggle to work within younger groups
but actually research by laura
karstensen at the stanford center on
longevity indicates that
multi-generational teams are more
successful than omnigenerational
ones one of my best colleagues at pwc
was a retired partner who continued to
engage with student events well into his
60s
it was amazing having someone like him
sharing his wisdom
his energy was infectious and i would
work with him again in a heartbeat
i'm sure that people listening to me
today are leaders who are hiring
my prime message to you
is not to be afraid to build
multi-generational teams
it is strategic for your business
and contributes to your personal career
longevity
we can confidently say that people in
their 30s or 40s today will work another
40 or 50 years
while we consider a career with multiple
pivots there are basic skills like
communicating and collaborating with
people that should be mastered
but this is an exciting
lifelong journey and you can start it
today
[Music]